hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and i'm sure that you've all heard the
excitement the
worries the news overall over the last
few years about
gene editing the possibility of editing
human genes
at a very detailed level not to mention
plant and animal genes of course
today's gasfidor ornov is actually not
just one of the world's experts he
coined the term
gene editing and he's been active in the
field since the beginning so he knows
what he's talking about
and i know that as well as prospects for
curing diseases and stuff like that
there are worries
about you know it would be good to cure
diseases
using gene editing but what if someone
made super soldiers and they became
bad like the red skull instead of good
like captain america wouldn't that be
bad
so at the end of the this interview i
asked theodore i said you know
as responsible as we might want to be
as scientists as countries as
international regulatory
agencies isn't it coming to the point
where this is almost
too easy and almost anyone will be able
to do
gene editing and make designer babies in
their
basements or their bedrooms as it were
and his answer was a little bit
surprising he said
absolutely it's gonna happen uh and
that's a little bit of a wake-up call
you know it
is kind of easy to play around with the
human genome
and we're gonna have to deal with that
in one way or the other this all this
stuff came about over just the last 10
years or even five years
uh with a wonderful little gizmo called
crisper cass which you've probably heard
about
crispr cas9 uh jennifer dudena
emmanuel charpentier and other
researchers figured out how to basically
borrow a mechanism that had already been
invented by biology right this is
something that exists
in bacteria in order to fight off
viruses so the crispr cas9 system can
recognize
a bad virus and then go in and attack
and neutralize it
and the way that it neutralizes it is by
snipping its dna
and either just tearing it apart or by
inserting something
to make it not so bad so the human
beings realized oh my goodness
bacteria have already figured out how to
do this we can use their technology and
adapt it to our own
needs so it's no doubt that we are at
the beginning the very dawn of the gene
editing era
there's no doubt this will be very very
good for a lot of reasons
there's no doubt this is going to be
scary and new for a lot of reasons
so i thought it'd be a lot of fun to
talk to someone who's been there
before the crispr cast 9 revolution and
is still there working at the front
lines
on both what gene editing is how it
works and what it's going to mean for us
in the years to come so this is a great
conversation with theodor ornov
let me just quickly mention also before
we start that
this podcast is being released the day
before
the paperback release of my book
something deeply hidden so if any of you
out there
are on the one hand paperback book
readers and on the other hand not yet
enthusiastic enough to have purchased
the hard
copy the hardback version rather of uh
it's still a hard copy if you get the
paperback version
the hardback version of something deeply
hidden and you want to know about
quantum mechanics
many worlds and some of the interesting
ideas going on in physics with emergent
space time and stuff like that
be sure to rush out to your local or
virtual bookstore and pick up a copy of
something deeply hidden i will
appreciate it
the universe will appreciate it and with
that let's go
[Music]
peter ornoff welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you for having me
i'll actually give you a special welcome
because uh i've noticed that the past
few months it's not been easy to get
biologists especially molecular cell
biologists onto the show they're
they're somehow uh their attention is
being absorbed
by something else by this weird virus
that is sweeping the world so uh are you
one of these people whose attention has
been diverted from your regular work or
have you sort of stubbornly pressed
forward with your basic research even in
the middle of the pandemic
i have been swept away by a tsunami
known as the pandemic and as i look
around
my professional life none of the objects
so familiar to me which is my beloved
crisper cast which is the
the protein that we use to genetic do
genetic engineering
um and the the human cells
that i do genetic engineering on whether
they happen to be
blood stem cells or lung cells
or brain cells none of them are around
me
instead i'm surrounded by uh
snot and spit there is no way to say it
except to say it because
those are the two types of specimens or
as
physicians say clinical matrices that we
use to test individuals for virus
and in fact for the past four and a half
months
i'd say 99.73 of my life has been
devoted to that
and productively so do you think that
the uh the skill set that you had
coming in has been uh well calibrated
for the challenges of this
you know if you'd asked me 35 years ago
when i first
walked into a freshman year biology
class
would there ever be a chance that
the types of things you're going to
learn would have a real world impact on
clinical care i'd say probably not
because
as many of my peers i signed up
to be a research scientist in biology
because i love the natural world i think
living systems are the most amazing
thing out there although i suspect as a
physicist
you might politely disagree but we're
ecumenical here at the mindscape podcast
don't worry
[Laughter]
and i thought i would spend the entirety
of my life in the
beautiful ivory tower of academia
studying fondly my
esoteric basic science question the
what happened was one divided by that um
20 years ago i had the good fortune of
joining a biotech where i then spent
15 years developing ways to genetically
engineer people to treat disease
which is not exactly ivory tower and
then two years ago when i joined the
faculty here at berkeley
i did so to continue that work on trying
to use genetic engineering to treat
disease
and then of course the pandemic hit in
it's kind of amazing to me
that the the central
tool that the nation and the world
needs so desperately to deal with the
pandemic which is testing
do you or do you not have the virus
that the mechanics under the hood
of what it takes to answer that question
are actually taught to every single phd
in my field which is molecular cell
biology
in the first month of them joining the
lab
and again if you if you walk around here
at berkeley and ask the first year
graduate student
do you think that whatever you're
learning will be used for clinical care
not many of them will say oh absolutely
but it happens to be the case that the
elementary skill sets of testing for the
virus
are the same elementary skill sets that
i learned
oh my goodness in late september 1990
when i was a first year graduate student
at brown
yeah and it seems literally
it's literally in the last century and
yet
the the fundamental mechanics of how one
diagnosis an individual
to have the virus rely on i guess
decades-old techniques which are
tried and true oh that's actually good
to know i mean i i
it makes me think that if ever the world
comes into a state where
my skill set is called upon to help in
some tangible way
we're in really big trouble much bigger
trouble even though we are now so
glad to hear the biologists i am just
visualizing this gathering of some
uh legislative body that says yes
at this point we need a cohort of
theoretical physicists
it did happen in the manhattan project
but it's different now yeah
i i by the way of course i'm joking one
of one of the truly remarkable things
about what you do and what i do
is the relevance and the resonance is
unpredictable like yeah
i think most people don't know that the
gps on their phones
uh works on einstein's uh theory of
relativity right yeah absolutely yeah
absolutely and just but i mean no i i
swear to you that dude that the majority
of people who'd use that
just don't don't who use gps just don't
think about that
similarly i think most people who get
diagnosed who get tested for the virus
they don't really think about the
mechanics and the fact that
the mechanics of the testing have to do
with really
foundational tools of my field which is
molecular biology that have been
developed over the past 50 years
right it's just not something that's in
the headlines daily
and yet here we are basic biologists
used to
sitting in our with our test tubes and
ourselves
in isolation of a laboratory um
finding ourselves in the in the in the
minds of the public like i i
i say to people oh you know rna
extraction
and lay people ask me oh do you do that
qpcr thing or do you do something else
and i go well i never thought that the
word qpcr would be used which stands for
quantitative polymerase chain reaction
by the way
uh would be ever would ever emerge in a
layperson conversation yet here we are
well this is a good segue because what i
actually want to do is get into
crispr and gene editing and then we can
see
if that circles us back to fighting
viruses and so forth so
uh for we take it that our audience
knows
what dna is that our genetic information
is stored in dna
and also probably most people out there
have this feeling that there's
been this revolution in the past few
years
in terms of editing the dna with this
crispr cass
stuff so maybe you can just tell us
you're one of the world's experts what
is crispr
what does it go around crisping and what
are we going to use it for
oh my goodness you can skip what are we
going to
we'll get there we'll get there later
what is it how does it work let's put it
that way
so so asking me about crispr is a bit
like asking a koala
what it thinks about eucalyptus leaves i
could
go on and on and on
the reason that we coined the term gene
editing
as an umbrella phrase to describe ways
of precise genetic engineering
is by explicit analogy to word
processing
both crispr and the technologies that
preceded it
which accomplished the same thing due
to the human genetic code or as it
happens
to the genetic code of a cow or
to the genetic code of a maze plant and
i use these three examples deliberately
because these are
living things that have been genetically
edited
or crispered
this technique does to the dna of a corn
plant
a cow or a human precisely what your
favorite word processor
would do to text you open
um a narrative a document on your
computer screen you use your mouse
to click on a bit of text and then you
type on your keyboard
whatever desired edit
you wish and so i'm delighted that this
term gene editing that my colleagues and
i
came up with 15 years ago is universally
adopted
and in fact people talk about gene edit
gene edited organisms
or we introduce this edit into a human
cell
precisely in the way that people
describe
introducing an edit into a document that
was our explicit goal and i guess we
succeeded
but i think that maybe people take that
analogy too literally
uh you know they have the idea that
you're just laying out the dna
on a slab and then you go and copy and
paste something like that i mean
the messy biology of it is a bit more uh
intricate
um that would be the understatement of
the year
i i i think what was einstein's favorite
phrase everything should be made as
simple as possible but not necessarily
simpler
yes so in in telling you how gene
editing
broadly and how crispr specifically
works i
really need to carefully walk that line
to not not in
not oversimplify
i think a good place to start is by
saying the following
human dna is very long
you know your audience is doubtless
familiar with the number 6.6 times 10 to
the 9th
letters of genetic code is what it takes
to build a human being
now a good way to think about how long
that is
is as follows if you read the genetic
code one letter at a time
a c t g once one second at a time
it'll take you a century to read the
entire human genome
so first the human genome is very long
this is also true of the cow and this is
also true for core
second with the exception of microbes
like
really small things that move around and
leave their little independent lives
most living systems don't like their dna
changed in any way at all
and this is because dna is you know
essentially the
the storage document for who who they
are yeah
and mother nature protects the integrity
of the genetic material
so and you you can see how
extraordinary this repair machinery is
if you look at folks who have um
the misfortune of not having the
machinery to repair damage
so for example there are folks with rare
diseases who cannot tolerate sunlight
because um they don't have the right
machinery to fix damage to the dna
and they need to wear you know sunscreen
spf 10000
right and in fact they sell they near
never venture out into the daylight
they have to basically be active at
night so
not only does our does our dna refuse to
be changed
our dna has a large number of molecular
machines
that literally babysit it and if
something damages it
and what are kind what are the kinds of
things that damage dna
so i mentioned sunlight so uv rays
create a particular kind of damage
chemicals can damage can damage dna so
for example
you know the reason smoking causes
cancer is it has a chemical which
physically damages the dna and the
repair machinery doesn't get to it in
time
and you get you get genetic changes that
cause cancer
the the other type of damage that our
dna gets all the time
and this is the most interesting one for
people who want to understand how gene
editing works
is is actually the most drastic one
which is literally taking scissors
and cutting the familiar double-stranded
helix
into two so if you think about the two
the two individual strands of dna
winding around each other in that
beautiful double helix
now imagine taking scissors and
literally cutting that thing
so that you have now where you had two
double helixes
one double helix you now have two so
this is the type of damage that occurs
um spontaneously just human cells just
going about their business
sometimes the dna just breaks um
humans most often experience it in fact
at the doctor's office so when you get a
chest x-ray
i guess i suppose an assay that's really
important right now
given the pandemic or when you go to the
dentist to get the dental x-ray
um the the the rays hit your dna and
your dna
i don't want to make your audience
squirm
with fear next time they're in the
dentist chair uh other than for
anticipation i don't know
there's no we don't need additional
reasons to not want to go to the dentist
but bottom line is that the the x-rays
that are used to take a picture of your
teeth and of your mouth
damage the dna
every every bit of dna they encounter by
by
basically cutting it and the reason this
this break is so dangerous
is we've all learned about chromosomes
we have
uh 46 of them 23 pairs one from mom one
from dad for each one
and we we've all learned and forgotten
in high school about mitosis this
beautiful process where
when a cell needs to divide it makes a
copy of all the chromosomes
and one copy goes to the cell on the
left one copy goes to the cell on the
right
now can you imagine if if one of these
chromosomes has a break
this means that during cell division
that broken piece will just
be left behind and that means losing
all the genes that are on that broken
off piece
and that the overwhelming majority of
the time
is genetic is a genetic loss that human
cells cannot tolerate
you can't just get rid of human genes
left and right now
you can get rid of some but the notion
that there would be a break on one of
the chromosomes such that an entire
chunk of it just gets lost
that's incompatible with forget human
beings being alive it's incompatible
with human cells being alive
but people should still go to the
dentist because the reason
that x-rays whether of a chest or of
your
oral cavity or that your exposure to
ionizing radiation from the sun when you
take
a commercial flight again not many
people are flying these days but back
when they used to
the the sun will emit rays and it will
hit your dna and your dna will be broken
into pieces
so mother nature has evolved
a machine to rapidly heal the break
and i'll speak more to this machine in a
second except i think it's really
important to appreciate how
ancient the machine is you know life on
earth is
what 4.5 billion years old 3.5 you know
whatever the number um
the machinery that heals the brakes
is one of the oldest molecular machines
we know so to give you
just to give you a representative
example budding yeast the tiny yeasties
that give us
bread and wine and beer and humans
their machinery for repairing that kind
of damage
is so similar that biologists who study
that repair machinery in human cells
use the exact same nomenclature for the
bits and pieces of it as the biologists
who study yeast
and one thing your audience may not know
about experimental biologists is they
would rather use each other's
toothbrushes than use each other's
nomenclature
so when people who study human biology
use the same gene names as the people
who study yeast
that is really to acknowledge the
majesty of mother nature as having
evolved something
a very long time ago hundreds and
hundreds of million years ago
and then preserving it okay so so far
we've spent a number of minutes
discussing the fact that when our dna is
broken
um well you know it just gets fixed and
what does that have to do with genetic
engineering
yeah so at this point um
and one of the themes i'd love to return
to a couple of times as i share with you
and your audience
the marvelous thing that's gene editing
is how often
in the let's think about this
year old scientific history of gene
editing and because that's when gene
editing really began it began in 1994
1995
in the laboratory of a scientist at
memorial sloan kettering in new york
named marie jason and she's actually
still there and leads the field and
she's absolutely wonderful
and in that in the 25 year
history of developing gene editing as a
tool
one of the things we've consistently
marveled is
how many of the discoveries that have
given us
remarkable recent advances in gene
editing so for example there was
recently
a person her name is victoria gray and
she was comfortable disclosing publicly
that she is a
a subject that's a strong word to use
and that's a technical word in the world
of clinical trials
to describe a human being who has
consented to participate in
in a clinical trial of an experimental
therapeutic and so she's the subject on
the clinical trial to do gene editing
for sickle cell disease which she has
she got gene edited i think about a year
ago when she no longer has sickle cell
disease
which is kind of astonishing so crispr
in seven years
went from being uh in eight years i
guess history 2020 time flies my
goodness
in eight years from when jennifer doudna
here on the berkeley campus discovered
how crispr works
we went in just eight years from the
discovery to a cure
but jennifer doudna's work was focused
on fundamental biology she wasn't trying
to build and she herself widely
acknowledges
he was not trying to build a gene editor
to treat sickle she's just a curious
scientist fascinated by how
mother nature works similarly the
beginnings of geneticity emerged out of
a fundamental curiosity
that people had about how do human cells
repair
damage let me pause for a moment to
recommend the great courses plus
this is a streaming service that gives
you instant access to
a wide variety of high-level courses so
that you can learn about things in the
privacy of your own home
at your convenience i love the fact that
there's such a wide variety of topics
being explored from oceanography to
history
to philosophy to food and wine and music
for example there's one interesting
course i came across on digital media
literacy
it's simply called fighting
misinformation so it's a great courses
level
introduction to how to be a smarter
consumer
of what you read about and find online
the great courses plus is great because
it's really convenient you can watch it
on your computer
you can listen to it it can be on your
mobile device on your tv with your
family or what have you
now is the perfect time to sign up for
the great courses plus because mindscape
listeners can get a free
trial today if they go to this special
url
the greatcoursesplus.com mindscape
that's t-h-e great courses plus dot com
slash mindscape and so what emerged
by the way it's going to get a little
bit technical
but you have my word it's technical of
the good kind where i'm hopeful that at
the end of this
of the 60 seconds is going to take me to
dive into this rabbit hole of
technicality
you will go oh yeah okay that makes
sense we love it that's why we're
basically
good so there are basically two ways to
repair a broken chromosome the first one
is the most logical one
you just put the dna back together in
them
so that pathway is called
rather you know not creatively that's
called end joining
again we could have found a style a more
stylish name but there you have it
and one of the things that's remarkable
about it
is sometimes when mother nature puts the
two ends back together again
she loses a letter or two
why well you know mother nature has
reasoned that
quote unquote only five percent of human
dna is actually
coding for genes and
that means that only five percent of the
breaks
will happen um in areas of
sort of in areas of the genome that make
proteins that make you and i
and thus you know what one in 20
is okay furthermore it's not that every
time a break happens mother nature makes
a mistake
it's just that she makes the mistakes
some of the time
and that is one the first key
tool in the gene editors
toolbox is the ability to cut
a gene of interest and the two examples
i will give you are ones that actually
are in the clinic
right now one is to
cut a gene that makes humans susceptible
to hiv
and the other one is to
cut a gene that
prevents this is where it's going to get
fun
that prevents the production of a
desired form of hemoglobin
and in both cases you can imagine a
second where if you cut a gene
that hiv needs to replicate or
if you cut a gene that prevents the
production of a healthy hemoglobin
you could immediately see why that could
be potentially clinically useful
right you could take a person with hiv
get rid of that gene and maybe the virus
will stop doing what it does
or you can take a human being with
sickle cell disease
somebody who cannot make normal globe
hemoglobin cut that other gene
and you know mother nature will start
making the normal hemoglobin
and i wouldn't be dragging you through
all of these technicalities if that
hadn't been done and if that hadn't
actually worked
on living people not in a you know one
of those
science fiction novels i i once
uh typed the word crispr on amazon by
mistake i was going to search the
literature and i was just so ups
um i was i was trying to buy a book for
my kid and i typed crispr as a
as a by newtonian inertia in this
birchbox and the first thing that came
out on amazon
is is a novel called crispr the
apocalypse
sure someone's going to write that book
you know once it's out there it's going
to happen
uh you know i i i recommend against it
because the the tagline goes
uh a dramatic novel of planetary
disaster
uh driven by brilliant scientists and
maniacal russians
i'm not making this up and so jennifer
dowd i
told jennifer doudou when i saw this
that you know it goes brilliant
scientists as maniacal russians
i said that between her and i we have
the two positions covered there you go
but so far we're just we're just cutting
dna right i mean
my impression is we can insert also oh
we're getting
straight to that so but when the dna is
cut it doesn't just shred
it comes back together again but you
gain or lose a few letters
and it turns out because of the way
genes work because of the way the
genetic
code works if you gain or lose
one or two letters in a gene
that actually kills the gene now your
readers
will your audience will remember from
high school biology that the genetic
the the elementary word of the genetic
code is
is a group of three for example the word
a t g is a word in the genetic code and
it says start
the word taa in the genetic code is a
word and it says
stop and the
the letter the word t t t
in the genetic code is a word that says
please insert the amino acid
phenylalanine
um um and so you know i'm not going to
recite the genetic code because that's a
fantastic way to put people to sleep
um but that means that if you lose three
letters
you're still okay you're still okay
because you've just script a word
and the text still makes sense for
example you know to be or not to be that
is question whether it is nobler you
know we just lost the word the
but it's still intelligible
whereas in genetic text which is read as
a continuous string if you gain or lose
just a letter or two
everything after the mistake is
gibberish
right scientists call this a frame shift
which means an inability to correctly
interpret where the genetic text
starts and ends its words so
this ability to break a gene or get rid
of a gene by
cutting it and then letting mother
nature somewhat
error prone and joining process
give you a what's called a gene knockout
is actually really useful clinically i
mentioned
to you this business about hiv and
sickle cell disease
it's useful for agriculture so for
example the first
genetically engineered gene edited crop
that will be marketed in the united
states not gmo gmos have been
on the market since the 90s and as your
audience knows
more than 90 percent of corn cotton and
soybean
grown in the united states are actually
old-school transgenic gmos
no this is a genetic crop and the first
gene edited crop will be corn it will be
waxy
and it will be used for the production
of starch and it will not be an
insertion or a precise repair of
mutation it will be actually such a gene
knockout
so that's the story of knockout ranging
from
corn that has desired properties for
making of torch
two human beings being gene edited to
deal with their hiv or sickle cell
disease
there's one other tool in the arm in the
armamentarium of a gene editor and
that's the ability to repair
mutations and if you want to be so
ambitious
to insert larger stretches of genetic
text
so how does that work well
i i'm going to have to ask you and the
audience to step back
yet again to the fundamental biology of
how mother nature deals with these
rather dangerous breaks
right we talked about the fact that the
simplest thing to do is just
put the two ends back together again and
march on
mother nature is concerned in fact about
precisely the gain or loss of genetic
information
so she evolved a separate way to heal
the brakes
which is achieves the same effect the
the break is healed
but how is magnificently different
and this is one of those things well
well i should say that
podcasts are one of my favorite things
because i can bring them with me
wherever i am
this is one of those where i wish i
could magically pop out of your
audience's
podcast uh device and start waving my
hands in the air
because this is one of those picture
worth a thousand words kinds of things
but let me do my best
the other way to repair a break
is to find an unbroken identical dna
molecule
and literally do a control
c control v right
copy paste the missing genetic
information
from an unbroken intact normal template
now where on earth does mother nature
have an
unbroken intact template well
actually many of your cells currently
have such a template and
in fact um your skin cells your
your bone marrow cells your the lining
of your
intestine and your mouth
any time cells divide they have to copy
the dna
and therefore every time mother nature
copies one of your chromosomes it makes
an identical copy
and i should say in one of those ways in
which geneticists
have come up with nomenclature that is
the bane of existence of all pre-medical
students on planet earth
is that identical copy of dna is not
called a twin which would be logical
it's called a sister i can explain why
it's one of those terms that really
should be retired but never will
we just have to live with it okay so yes
in
all our cells that divide every piece of
dna
is flanked by an identical copy which
unfortunately is called a sister
so mother nature evolved this beautiful
pathway where if
one chromosome is broken that
broken end literally it's very sweet
it's actually it's kind of warm and
fuzzy it there's this little broken end
and it searches it truly performs a
search like waving its little molecular
hand around can somebody help me
and what's it searching for it is
searching for a molecule a dna molecule
of identical sequence
and when it finds it it automatically
assumes
that it is the sister molecule that is
its kin it's identical
and mother nature then evolved a way to
copy paste
the information at the break from the
sister chromosome into the broken one
and heal the rib
heal the break i know that's a lot to
take in
so i'll just recap one chromosome was
broken
the broken end starts to search
for something in its molecular
neighborhood that is identical in
sequence
typically it's what's called a sister
chromatid which is identical
it copies the missing information from
the sister into
itself and life can continue yeah
so what in heaven's name does that have
to do with gene
editing much to everyone's
surprise and as discovered
by a number of people actually studying
little budding yeast
and then this discovery was expanded to
human cells
you can fool mother nature now you can't
fool her all the time
but sometimes you do so when with
spectacular results
what you can do is this take a
chromosome and break it
and we can we can we will speak in a
second as to how you actually do that
what are those molecular scissors
normally that break would be either
repaired by putting the ends back
together which is fine not nothing we
can do about that
or alternatively it will be repaired by
trying to reach out to the sister
and saying listen lend me a helping hand
here i need i'd like some missing
genetic information
so it was discovered that you can
basically stick
inside a yeast cell or a human cell
a bunch of dna that is
identical in dna that you have made in
the lab so this is
if this if this is the part where your
audience hears the laughter of a
maniacal scientist going you know
it is alive this would be a good time to
evoke the stereotype
um nobody ever said it is alive in fact
most of us
in fact all of us who work at the bench
are quite quite silent because we focus
on what we're doing
so we don't you know rip rip our lab
coats off and run around the streets of
berkeley
saying eureka
when you break a chromosome in a in a
precise location and then put inside the
cell
a piece of dna that is identical to the
broken stretch
but you make a tiny change you literally
change
one letter mother nature will not notice
and will copy paste that change into the
chromosome
it's amazing that this works but it does
and astonishingly well
so and i'll just give you some numbers
which are kind of amazing
um scientists have performed this
process
on human blood stem cells these are the
cells that make
red blood cells white blood cells
platelets
so inside your bone marrow inside inside
the bones that form your pelvis or
inside the the largest um bone of your
of your one of the largest bones in your
body which is i think the humerus
there's a cavity and inside the cavities
is the
famous stem cell which which makes all
the blood blood
blood stem cells that circle around you
and keep you alive
you know people have shown that you can
take a bunch of cells like that
and make a break and then provide a
a decoy a trojan horse a repair template
that
places a new piece of genetic
information into the chromosome
and literally half the cells politely
acquire that new genetic change
well so i want to give you this number
this is this is important
i want to sort of dig in on this because
this is what is confusing to me so
um we're imagining that this is a
potentially grown up adult organism
and it's not that you have to go in uh
with a microscope and look at every
single one of their cells
and edit it you can insert
an edit and it will spread through at
least many of the other cells is that
right
yes and it gets even better to some
extent we can control how this spreads
now
i want to be clear what it is that is
spreading
it is not the case although that would
be kind of amazing
if a genetically edited cell starts to
say to its neighbors guess what i've
been gene edited do you want some of my
dna
no that's not what happened although
that would be kind of astonishing
but by the way i should say that there
are examples in biology like that
bacteria do that all the time
but human cells normally do not
share dna with each other instead what
spreads is the gene editor itself
which as i'm about to explain is this
tiny molecular machine that we
engineer in the lab and then we stick it
inside the cells and we can we have two
ways of doing that
if you want to gene edit an organ such
as the eye or the liver
you actually have to inject the gene
editor into the body
typically that's done by enveloping the
editor in a virus
and this is just before people right now
saying that you're going to inject
people with a virus is
not exactly what is what to say you're
not going to get big bugs asking for
that
right it's a bit like saying during a
plague would you like some rats
no we do not want more rats um so no
this is a very different
virus it's not stars cov2 it's innocuous
and furthermore it's made even more
innocuous by gutting it of whatever it
had and replacing its insides with the
gene editor
so what you basically do for the eye is
you inject the virus into the eye
and it goes and enters the cells
or for the liver you inject the virus
directly into the bloodstream
and the virus homes to the liver and
infects the liver cells and delivers the
gene editor
and both of these things are being done
clinically right now for congenital
blindness and for hemophilia
respectively so
i'm deliberately not using hypothetical
examples there are gene edited people on
the planet who have been treated using
this approach
and is the stuff that you're editing
into the genes
um stuff that you get from a healthy
cell or are there
gene programmers uh actually writing the
gctas in the correct order to get
something new
the sky is the limit i can tell you
what's happening now and what we'd like
to do
so for now um the genetic engineering of
cells um organs in in living humans
so whether you engineer the eye or the
liver and just to give you a sense of
what's on the horizon
i think the next genetic engineering
will be
for muscular dystrophy so it will be the
muscle and then
people are very excited about applying
gene editing to the lung
in all those cases what's being done is
either
repair of a mutation that causes disease
or the addition of a normal healthy
human gene
that corrects the defect in a natural
gene so there is no
quote unquote genetic augmentation or
genetic embellishment
right having said that and here's you
know this is where it gets
fun in fact one of the earliest and
biggest success stories not in gene
editing
but in the bigger field of human genetic
engineering was in fact precisely in
such genetic augmentation
now genetic engineering of people
started in 1989 so started a pretty
pretty it's pretty remarkable it's 13
years old
and it started not by precise editing
you know here's a gene here let's fix
letter number four
it started by just inserting genes using
viruses
and there are many reasons why one can
do that but the most remarkable one
that's currently not just widely
practiced but it's enough
there are two approved medicines in that
class is something called cancer
immunotherapy
and the basic idea that emerged in the
late 90s early 2000s was you could
cause the body's own immune system to
attack the cancer
and the way that's done is you engineer
a molecule this is literally laboratory
engineering you engineer a molecule
that will cause your immune system cell
to attack the cancer cell
then you take the immune system cells
out you stick a gene
that encodes or specifies the production
of of that new molecule
you put the cells back in and lo and
behold
the cells now re-routed
or reprogrammed i know those are big
words
reprogrammed well i mean there is a lot
of imagery associated with yours people
think
people think gothica people think
whatever they saw on instagram
and you know one has to be careful with
language because
you know words have meaning so i i'm
always very mindful to not say things
like
you know this is why i think partly why
we invented the word gene editing
because we wanted to
contrast it with you know good old gmos
because the i don't think
right i i think the damage that has been
done by the publicity around
gmos i i think is never going to be
repaired i think we're just
stuck with that um they're they're
they're actually safe but the public
will never accept that fact so you know
we just have to move on
but the big point that you seem to be
making about the use of gene editing for
fighting diseases is in some way you're
giving the body
the resources that it needs to fight it
in a very
natural biological way correct so for
example our ability to fight hiv by
getting rid of that ccr5 gene that's the
name of the gene
is based on a discovery made here in the
san francisco bay area during the
the tragedy of the uh of the aids
pandemic when uh
physicians discovered here in san
francisco actually that there are folks
whose partners had succumbed to aids and
these folks reported having
unprotected sex with them and yet were
virus free and when their dna was steady
they turned out to be naturally
lacking that gene and that told
physicians first of all that you can
lose that gene without any overt
symptoms
and second that if you get rid of that
gene you could potentially protect a
person from hiv
so natural genetic variation or
transferring genetic variation naturally
from one person to another
became a therapeutic modality similarly
for the sickle cell disease treatment
strategy
that was used to treat as best as we can
tell cure victoria grade
there are people who have this natural
variant of this gene
it's basically a reduced form reduced
function of that gene
that really make normal globin and it
was the transfer of that natural
variation from
those people to people with the disease
that is currently being practiced
so yes you're exactly right this is
moving natural variance from one person
to another
and is this i mean how optimistic can we
let ourselves be
about you know the fight against cancer
and the dramatic side or even just like
allergies hay fever on the less dramatic
side are are we gonna
be able to wipe these out someday i know
that predicting time scales is always
hard but is that a realistic target
so i can tell you what's gonna happen in
the next five to ten years okay and at
that point we we completely fall off the
cliff of yogi berry you know it's
it's hard to make predictions especially
about the future yeah and the reason i
say this is if you know
if the if the history of science and
biology my field
of the past three decades teaches us
anything is never underestimate
the remarkable things that scientists
can discover that mother nature gives us
you know if you if you had told me 10
years ago when we were doing gene
editing with first generation tools
that there is a scientist at berkeley
who will discover a molecular machine
that will
comes from bacteria that will use rna to
find its way to human genes and
will cure sickle cell disease i would i
would um
probably ask for you to get some health
with help with your mental health right
and i would be egregiously wrong because
that's exactly what happened
so super hard to extrapolate beyond 10
years because we don't know what
technologies will
will show up but here's what's going to
happen in the next five to 10.
there absolutely will be dramatic
advancements in the treatment of certain
forms of cancer using this approach
so certain previously incurable cancers
are now curable
a lot of people are working on the
application of gene editing of the human
immune system to eradicate more
challenging cancers
there's early stage progress a lot of
work remains but i am
completely convinced that the next five
to ten years we'll see more cures when i
know cure is a big word
um the other one is certain forms of
genetic disease
so the particular ones that i'm thinking
about are
sickle cell disease which is remarkable
there is a hundred thousand americans
suffering from it it's a terrible
disease
hemophilia uh you know one in one in
five to ten thousand
uh boys born um in in the united states
for example have hemophilia disorder and
blood clotting
i think those two we can we can
realistically
expect for the public health burden of
those diseases
uh and on the folks who have the disease
will be dramatically reduced
i think my other biggest area of
excitement for this technology is
actually the treatment of pain
okay so there are there are forms of you
know as the tragedy of the fact that
tens and tens of thousands of our fellow
americans have died
um due to overdoses from um synthetic
painkillers
is these things are addictive they're
very powerful but they're very addictive
so you
so you get prescribed something um um
for pain and you know you get addicted
to it and you die of that which is
like such a tragedy so um the the worst
offender is this thing called fentanyl
which really really kills why does
fentanyl exist will fentanyl exist
because there are certain forms of pain
that don't respond to morphine
like cancer pain if you have cancer and
if you have metastasis
i'm not a physician but i've worked with
physicians for 25 years so i
i i try to carefully reproduce what i
learned from them
there are certain forms of cancer pain
they're called breakthrough cancer pain
for which there's
no no conventional um um opiate would
help and so there's synthetics
such as fentanyl which you give to to
folks with terminal cancer so that at
least they can die in dignity rather
than
succumb to horrific pain so we don't
need that thing to exist
we now know thanks to some remarkable
discoveries by geneticists that there is
a gene it's kind of astonishing there is
now we know two genes
and if you get rid of it people feel no
pain now
that's a bad thing right we you need to
feel pain uh
some pain yeah yeah you know
when you've cut yourself you're in
danger or you know there are many
reasons why pain sensation is good
but when you're when you have criminal
cancer and you have horrific pain
you don't need pain and so it turns out
that there are people
who don't have that gene they don't feel
pain and then there's a a different
group of people they're more rare
um they they don't just feel pain
they're naturally high so they're
they're
constantly in a good mood and so
one of the one of these genetic changes
is in a system that transmits pain from
your fingertip for example or your toe
you stubbed
through the spine to the brain and the
other uh genetic system
is the so-called endocannabinoid system
it's a it's mother nature's natural
painkillers
that we mother nature uses to get
ourselves
high in in just the right way and so it
turns out that we can use gene editing
to get rid of either one of the systems
or the other
and there are in fact early stage
efforts to try to make that into a
therapeutic
and so in just very realistic terms do i
see this entering the clinic in the next
three to five years
absolutely do i see this having as
having a strong potential for becoming
a non-opioid non-addictive way to treat
certain forms of chronic pain i
absolutely do and then the last
um which again you know 10 years ago i
would have probably suggested you get a
reality check
but today this is this is this is how
fast things are moving
i think there are certain forms of
common disease for which i really see a
major promise for gene editing
and i say this because of some recent
remarkable discoveries
about uh natural protection for heart
disease and
if there's a theme emerging i talked
about people who were resistant to hiv
i spoke to you about people who don't
feel pain
i'm now going to share information about
people who never get heart attacks
and you know i i have a family history
of cardiovascular disease
so i would love to have that form of
that gene but unfortunately i don't
the gene has one of those jaw-breaking
names that mean really nothing to lay
people it's called pcsk9
but it turns out that those rare
individuals who don't have a normal copy
they seem to be fine except they don't
get heart attacks well it's an
exaggeration of course but
their risk for heart attack is just
vanishingly low
okay okay so you know what are we going
to do with that yeah ask a mother nature
for a different gene
no we ask gene editors to get rid of it
and in fact there are active efforts and
clinical trials could start as early as
2022
to take people with a severe risk for
cardiovascular disease in particular for
heart attacks and just get rid of this
gene prospectively
before they die of a heart attack so you
know in brass tax terms
you will you ask me well what are we
looking forward to i'm looking forward
to a fundamentally new way to treat
cancer
a fundamentally new way to approach
genetic disease because of course we can
repair mutations things like hemophilia
or sickle cell disease
um i'm excited hugely excited about pain
uh not experiencing it but getting rid
of it and
um i'm really excited about certain
common diseases in particular
cardiovascular disease
beyond that yeah i mean let's let's uh
just go all the way and try to cure
aging while we're at it right
well okay so this is where i'm going to
be debbie downer or i suppose not debbie
downer but you know the
the classic saying is that pessimist is
a well-informed optimist
aging is not a disease the food and drug
administration and the european medicine
agency and the therapeutics good
administration
in the united states and europe and
in australia and health canada in canada
do not recognize aging as a disease
and this is for a good reason and you
cannot by definition begin a clinical
trial for a disease that doesn't exist
okay so um the other problem with doing
uh
clinical trials for longevity is these
trials take a while like imagine you had
them
so there is a well-studied variant of a
gene called igf it doesn't matter what
that stands for
and folks with certain variants of it
consistently live longer
they have a they don't just live longer
they have a longer health span which is
kind of amazing whoa
longer health span so now imagine a gene
editing trial where you know
uh the scientists at the innovative
genomics institute at the university of
california berkeley have
found a way to crank up the longevity
gene and
there we are with our with our frantic
look in our eyes and our lab coats
uh about to inject somebody with
longevity juice and then of course we
wait 45 years to see if they live longer
you realize that being deliberately
sarcastic because it's actually super
hard yeah it is super hard to do
so practical terms
i mean you're this is the difference
right because i'm a i'm a physicist who
thinks about
uh the cosmological lifespan of the
universe and you're someone who
actually has the capability of affecting
things in real ways over
five year time scales so if something
takes a century time scale you're like
yeah let's not think about it but
i want to think about that i mean is is
in a few generations
could we have little molecular machines
running around inside of us
uh curing uh or patching us up as
we get tiny little dings on our dna and
and therefore
not maybe making us immortal but
extending our lifespan by quite a bit
first of all i love the fact you know it
is it's such an affecting moment for me
you know the universe is what 13.4
billion years old something like that
0.8 yep um yeah i love the fact that you
guys know that to like the fraction of a
decimal that's just hysterical
for me you know 13.7 billion versus 13.9
yeah yeah and here i am stuck with the
fact that something like six months
versus a year
so i love the fact that they you know we
you uh the non-physicists
think of the think of the of the world
as on r and newtonian scale you know of
sort of meat
meters and centimeters and you think
that angstrom or subnets of angstrom and
we think in years and you think in
billions of years
i love that that's amazing so in
practical terms the way this is actually
going to proceed
is we need molecular machines
that crank up the body's defenses
against damage and that's imaginable
that's in fact not science fiction so
yes i
do envisage a future for example and
this is again i want to be very careful
because the world has enough uh uh
novels on amazon that describe maniacal
science and
engineering and gothica-like futures
so i do imagine a future where humans
acquire a molecular machine in their
liver
that helps the liver tolerate the many
perform the many functions that it does
and you know the liver is a primary
organ for detoxification right
and i absolutely see that
the other um the the other organ that i
think is
of huge huge interest and you will say
the brain no in fact it's not the brain
it's the kidney
so chronic kidney disease you know 30
plus million americans have it
you know the medicare spends more money
on uh dialysis
for that condition than the national
institutes of health spends a year on
its research budget so it's a huge
public health burden and it's a tragedy
for folks who have it
do i see a future where we engineer ways
to
make human kidneys carry some form of a
machine
that protects it against chronic kidney
disease yes i do
so i think the same could be true for
the heart
do i see a future where we either
genetic we are we sort of
we place inside the human heart a
molecular entity
that is wired
i don't want to say like i i don't see a
future where
we have a myocardial infarction and the
the infarct is repaired immediately but
i
absolutely see a future where the heart
carries now a molecular machine
where when there is a heart attack if
the person who had it survives it
that um the heart heals factor
i absolutely that that is not in in
other words
all the bits and pieces exist you know
it's a little bit like living on mars
right i mean
can we live on mars i mean yeah we have
to first of all get there safely
then we have to build a habitat and then
we have to find people who actually want
to do this
but like kind of all the bits and pieces
are in principle there
you just have to put them together so
when i'm describing all of these things
it's a little bit like
you know the concept of creating a
habitat on mars all the pieces are there
it's just going to take us
together how much of uh what we've been
talking about
is there's this divide between um
epigenetic editing and germline editing
which
i i suspect is very very important and
maybe you're a better person than me to
explain what the difference is
oh my goodness i hope your podcast is
five hours long
so let's do germline first very simple
it's it's it's one of those things where
things are as
binary as it gets germline editing of
human beings should never be allowed
under any circumstances period end of
paragraph
it's scientists don't like you to use
the word never
but this is one of those what is
germline editing it's
gene editing or other genetic
engineering that can be passed on to
future generations
there is no unmet medical need for it
the the public health burden of genetic
disease
that um exists and is quite substantial
can be and is being addressed by
other means which are safe and ethical
germline editing is unethical and in
fact illegal and useless for that
purpose
the only potential reason why people
would want to do the germline editing
is uh to for human enhancement and the
reason that is
should be forever banned is we don't
know how to enhance people
and imagine a setting the classic
example is
we know of a gene um
getting rid of which will somewhat
protect you from alzheimer's
it's called apoe4 if you happen to have
apoe4
and if you get rid of it your risk of
alzheimer's would will be dramatically
reduced
so now imagine we we you know we
fertilize an embryo
and a human embryo and then we get rid
of that gene and then we wait 18 years
to see whether that child became an
adult and then became an elderly human
and is in fact protected against
alzheimer's
there is no way to do this there's just
no
mechanical mechanical way um by
mechanical i mean just the way the
physical world works
i shouldn't probably say in your
presence physically that's okay
it makes sense society that
as i've learned through through years of
reading and
marveling at a late person's books about
theoretical physics
your world is getting more in the words
of alice in wonderland curiouser and
curious
it is you're not wrong yep so um i think
that
germline editing is just a non-starter
is fortunately illegal uh well it's not
illegal it's just not allowed in the
united states it's it's
it should be banned forever so now
epigenetic editing oh goodness
um i think you should start a timer
because i might just rant on and on
what epigenetics epigenetics is a change
in the way
an organism looks without a change in
their dna
and this is basically an
epigenetic mark is basically molecular
makeup
you know literally like lipstick or or
mascara that human dna
wears to try to instruct it what to do
so the genetic code specifies what the
genes
say epigenetics specify
whether they say it and how they say it
and when
right so a prime example of
epigenetics gone wrong are neural tube
defects in newborns
i'm sure you've heard that your audience
has heard of spina bifida
so that's not a genetic error it's an
epigenetic error and it has to do
with how the neural tube develops
and how during development of that
neural tube
the genes acquire these epigenetic marks
so not changes in the dna but in this
molecular makeup
and if the changes are placed
incorrectly
perhaps because mom's diet was deficient
in folate
and folate is a vitamin that provides an
essential
biochemical piece to the epigenetic
machinery
so if mom doesn't get enough folate in
her diet
then the epigenome here's a pretty word
not a genome the epigenome which is the
collection of
epigenetic marks that her baby's dna is
acquiring
that her baby's epigenome will be wrong
and that baby's at risk for getting
spina bifida
which is why folate supplementation
is a major success of public health for
prevention of neural tube defects
so scientists and physicians have
learned that if you supplement the diet
of a woman
who would like to become pregnant and of
a woman who is pregnant then she can
choose
to supplement her diet with folate or
before becoming pregnant and while
carrying the baby
and that will substantially reduce
although not completely eliminate
unfortunately the risk of her
um becoming uh delivering a child with
spina bifida although full disclosure i
believe i want to be very
very um what's the word i'm looking for
i want to be very respectful uh as all
people in my field of the fact that
they're
ultimately what we do is about folks
with the conditions
with a disability and their rights their
interests their feelings
uh are i don't want to sacred is a very
strong word but they kind of
are yeah and put them first primary
right and so i want to be very careful
here i you know
um i'm sure they're they're
we are trying to reduce the prevalence
of of this
um medical sim condition
while being enormously respectful
and supportive and caring for the folks
who have these conditions right i mean
right you know so there's that is what
drives all that we do having said that
folate supplementation if a woman
chooses to take it
will reduce the risk of that woman
having a child with a neural tube defect
why
because of an epigenetic effect so
believe it or not recent developments
have created not just
gene editing which is you know you
change the sequence of dna by either
repairing a mutation or getting rid of a
gene or adding a gene
you can also do epigenome editing what
does that mean you don't change the
genes you just change what the genes
do and that as it turns out can have
real
benefits in some settings so for example
you can tune the duration
of the effect where you know genetic
changes like diamonds
forever an epigenetic change does not
have to be forever
you can dial it in to last for a couple
of months for some reason
and if not it goes away and i wouldn't
be saying this to you if your humble
servant together with some colleagues at
the university of california san
francisco
carnegie mellon at the white house
wasn't working on a project funded by
darpa
to create such an epigenetic change
using crispr
in america's war fighters to protect
them from radiation damage in the
theater of war
in america's first responders to protect
them uh
for when they have to rush to the scene
of either potentially a nuclear accident
or
a dirty bomb scenario and also to
protect
folks in the united states who are about
to undergo radiation treatment for their
abdominal or pelvic cancers
in all these cases we are engineering a
crispr
which we hope will create for a few
weeks
an epigenetic edit to protect
the bone marrow and the gut of these
individuals
whether the warfighter the first
responder or the patient
in a radiation oncology ward or just a
month or so
from the danger of radiation poisoning
so this is a scenario
where an epigenetic edit is preferable
to a kinetic one
well i want to dig into why it's
preferable i mean if you could
uh do the same thing but make these
soldiers stronger
and more resistant to bullets
as well as radiation uh and why not make
it last a long time i mean
i'm asking leading questions because i
think these are good issues and we
shouldn't just
uh zoom over them we should sort of sit
down and think about what the issues are
so this is something that i myself and
all our colleagues and the department of
defense has thought hard about
um i mean you know america's warfighters
will stand up and defend her
whatever whatever the whatever the need
and so but we have to be respectful of
the fact that these women and men
have committed their lives to that and
we have to be respectful of that right
we can we cannot be and i'm not
suggesting you're saying that i'm just
saying
we have to be respectful of their
commitment to our country
and here i think the department of
defense wisely
and i concur with their judgment has
argued against
making a permanent change because you
know what
that system for protecting us against
damage
has its benefits you know if a cell is
too damaged
then you know it might die a normal
death
rather than survive and potentially
acquire a cancerous change
yeah in an extreme setting where a a war
fighter who is in the special forces the
tip of the
of the spear as as the department of
defense describes them
um are you know are are have to be
dropped from a helicopter
into a regime change scenario where
there is a nuclear fuel and this is a
realistic thing to contemplate
where that fuel can fall into the wrong
hands i mean they're putting their lives
on the line to save the world from
disaster
that's one scenario when we protect them
for for a month
against the harm that they can come in
in contact with
but when they go when they when they're
honorably discharged or
to leave the military whatever we want
them to go back to
lives pre-military so i would be i tell
you i would be
i would not agree right now to work
on a gene edit program for um
enhancing uh uh enhancements of that
type i
i just wouldn't um i epi edits sure
but the idea that i would permanently
genetically engineer a human being
and thus commit them to having that dna
for the rest of their lives
and this was an enhancement type edit i
don't know man it's a
it's that would be a hard pill for me to
follow well i'm very sympathetic to this
idea that
it's incredibly difficult to know what
all the possible ramifications are were
you to go
down that road right like even with the
best of intentions if you tried to make
people
uh you know healthier or had better
eyesight or whatever or
taller or bigger iqs it could ruin other
things that we have a difficult time
uh anticipating but i guess what i'm
what i'm thinking of
what i'm not doing is advocating it but
i'm what i'm doing is guessing
that someone's not going to feel that
way someone's just going to do it right
it's going to be done
somewhere in the world this technology
is becoming easier and easier to use
right like are there going to be
people in their garages 3d printing
crispr
programs to make different babies
absolutely and that's in fact already
happening
yeah uh i think that the tragedy of gen
que has alleged crime
is that i don't want to swear on air but
like i'm you can imagine i'm in certain
words here with your work
you know language that i
learned to use when i was drafted at the
age of 18 when i was drafting to the
soviet military
that i would have to flag on youtube i
understand yeah i know let's
but jungkook is a criminal
this is the chinese scientist who um who
actually did this to human babies right
for
allegedly allegedly yeah okay so he
performed two crimes
the first crime is he irreversibly
stained
my field of genetic engineering to treat
disease
with uh with a with a
imprint of designer baby
yeah you know you tell people i do
crispr people say oh do you make babies
do you make smarter babies
yeah no we don't we try to cure cancer
and sickle cell disease but yeah
but the other thing that's even a deeper
crime is he showed to the rogues of the
world that this can be done
i am absolutely convinced that there are
laboratories right now they're
underground i mean i don't mean
physically i mean metaphorically
yeah or who are enhancing quote-unquote
embryos for people with too much money
too much money and not enough
understanding of the science and not
enough ethics
um that's happening and i think that i
don't think there's
any way to prevent that from happening
because again this is why jennifer
dalton's discovery of how crispr works
is i mean revolution is not is not
enough
of a word it puts it put us in a
different world
right you know um
you know as a scientist i would say
phase transition but that's that's a
good way to
put people to sleep i mean maybe i know
maybe you know imagine metamorphosis
where you have a crawling caterpillar
and suddenly
you have a flying butterfly so
jennifer's discovery
converted my world from a crawling uh
crawling caterpillar to a flying
butterfly
just like we were moving in a
fundamentally different way we have
flight thank you very much
um so um it's it's it's
actually high school biology easy
so are will there be and are there
uh people who don't understand the
literature and who are delusional
doing that right now to themselves and
potentially human embryos there are
here's what to do about this first
embryo and baby editing has to be a
crime everywhere
to ensure that 100 percent of the time
that somebody
is outed somebody running you know 1 800
design your baby's jeans dot yeah call
every time these people are out there
they go to jail period and a paragraph
separately and that cannot eradicate
that because crispr is too
technologically straightforward like
you know i don't know anything about
nuclear reactors but i suspect that
building one requires a certain amount
of know-how
yes and you have to have the
infrastructure and you have to buy the
stock
so that's not true for crispr the
know-how is relatively modest and you
can buy the stuff
and you can buy this stuff sort of sotto
voce you don't have to tell the world oh
my god i'm doing crisper in my baby
so that has to be driven into as low a
prevalence as possible by making it
completely illegal
human somatic enhancement of consenting
adults
well let me give you an example botox is
legal for wrinkles
botox is botulinum toxin is
one of the most dangerous substances
on earth by weight the food and drug
administration has approved
a situation where people who don't like
wrinkles inject themselves with botox
so do i see a future where there's
crispr rocks i hope it's not cold that
that people inject into themselves to
get rid of wrinkles or whatever change
their eye color
i don't care as long as consenting
adults
apply to themselves things that
have passed regulatory review by the fda
by health canada
by the ema i'm totally fine but the key
issue here is consent
right as long as a human being with eyes
open
agrees then i see no reason difference
frankly you know people get tattoos all
the time
and then getting rid of them is a lot
harder
people need to understand that a gene
edit cannot be eliminated
and that they will live with the
consequences of that for the rest of
their lives but at the end of the day
will come down to free will
if it's legal for somebody to obtain a
piercing in a body part where most
people would rather not put a needle
it's perfectly fine for people to create
a double strand break in their dna using
a
a procedure that is safe and permanently
genetically modify them
so we should maybe shift our focus from
designer babies to designer grown-ups
there will be designer grown-ups for
sure there's no no question in my mind
and the only thing that needs to happen
for that
is a fewer years need to pass for the
fda to grow comfortable with a safety
and efficacy record
of gene editing for treating disease and
you know the classic example i'll give
you is statins statins were you know
everybody takes statins if they're at
risk of cardiovascular disease
but they were not initially developed
for prevention they were approved for
the treatment of rare forms of heart
disease
and when it was seen that they're safe
you know they're now over-the-counter
statins where i think they're about to
be
um so the same thing will happen with
gene editing once we know that it's safe
and effective to treat disease
somebody will show up and say oh you
know i'll give you an example if you get
rid of a gene called the androgen
receptor
and it's on the x chromosome and we know
where it is i know i can tell you
everything about it if you get rid of
that gene you will get rid of boldness
so you can put crispr in shampoo can you
imagine
yes the company that builds that i'm sad
to say will be more
will be more expensive than apple and
google yeah
because you know the amount of money
that people will spend on their vanity
as
experience has shown is pretty insane
so yeah that i totally see a setting
where there is a shampoo
i'm not i want to emphasize i i am
i haven't had any stimulants other than
coffee today
so do i see a future where there is a
crispr-like molecule formulated
in a special ink in a special
chemical formula to allow penetration of
the scalp and editing the androgen
receptor gene
in um the the stem cell uh at the bar at
the bottom at the root of each hair
follicle and thus prevent
a male pattern boldness absolutely that
this will happen this will happen
well i always like to say that i like to
end the podcast on optimistic note and
that's certainly one but just in case
there's another optimistic note out
there um do you have some final words
about how this all relates back to
uh the pandemic and our our current urge
to
shield ourselves from this nasty little
virus that's running around
i do i think that
real world solutions require
many different subunits and they don't
emerge from the same field
so for example my favorite example is
that
the space suit that neil armstrong
walked the moon
in was not made by one some giants
contractor it was made by playtex yeah
seamstresses at playtex
sewed the spacesuit so in 1969 i think
is when the moonshot was
this marvel of technology the rocket the
telemetry the fuel the engine blah blah
blah
and the spacesuit was sewn by
seamstresses of playtex
similarly the real world impact of any
technology such as crispr
on anything such as the pandemic
requires multiple technologies and other
things to converge in real people have
to wear masks
but i think we have entered two separate
ages in medicine the first one is we
have entered the age of the genetically
engineered human
that is irreversible there are now
approved medicines
for cancer and for genetic disease where
people get genetically engineered
this will only rise and over the next
decade or two
the public health burden of genetic
diseases and
infectious diseases and cancer will
start to
be lower in in the developed world where
there is access to
treatments of that type but we have also
entered the age where we don't just
read human dna we understand what human
dna says
and we're doing this at a pace that was
uh what was unimaginable before and
critically these discoveries are
translated into therapeutics or ways to
prevent disease
much faster than anyone thought possible
to take 15 years these days it takes two
two years ago regeneron discovered a
gene that protects from a non-alcoholic
theater hepatitis
which is a severe disease of the liver
two years later they're in the clinic
they're in the clinic
with them with a medicine rnai that
targets that gene
it's unimaginable that two years or only
two years pass
so as far as the pandemic is concerned
for these viruses or
other viruses i'm actually excited about
the prospect of genetic engineering
of humans to genetically vaccinate them
for viral infections now frankly
where i'd like to go first with this is
into the developing world
into parts of africa and asia where
there's not enough access to hiv
medication
to use gene editing to genetically
vaccinate folks at risk
for hiv against it preemptively i think
that that that would be
i mean obviously this would have to pass
regulatory review and would have to
you know talk past the highest rigor of
ethics
in terms of informed consent etc but i
think do i see a future
where we engineer preemptively
gene edits or epi gene edits
as this year's vaccine for sars kobe
7 to prevent us protect us from covet
uh covet 2026 which there will be kovit
2026 as we all know it's not just covet
19
yeah absolutely i mean we have entered
we have entered a very
formidable space where the technologies
have now converged where
genetic engineering or epigenetic
engineering of people is a clinical
reality and it's just going to grow in
scope
it really does make make me feel like
the
state of gene editing in 2020 is sort of
like
or making predictions about its future
it's like trying to predict the future
of the personal computer in the early
1980s right like there was clearly
something going on
and you could see that things would
happen but it's probably the
unanticipatable consequences that will
end up being the ones that will really
change things down the road
i could not agree with you more and you
know
sidney brenner one of my scientific
idols a nobel laureate and one of the
founders of modern experimental biology
said
progress in science comes from new
technologies and new
discoveries and new ideas probably in
that order which is a stunning thing to
say because he was the father of so many
ideas that changed the world
but techno we live in a we are in a
technology driven space
i completely agree with you uh i'm not a
computer person but you know clearly
miniaturization right
the transition from i'm old enough to
remember floppy disks
it's impossible to explain to my 21 year
old daughter what a floppy disk is
yeah yeah and so i do i anticipate
exactly as you said that
progress in human genetic and epigenetic
engineering in the clinic and for
disease protection and potential
enhancement will be as unpredictably
exciting
as what's happened from the good old you
know ibm pcat in 1986 or whatever
absolutely that's that is exactly what
will happen so if we
we just buckle our seat belts and and
either partici either make this happen
or or make use of
what's happening so yeah well we
appreciate very much you uh helping us
to buckle our seat belts here i think
it's going to be a wild ride
theodore or no thanks so much for being
on the windscape podcast
truly a pleasure
[Music]
you